last night at the White House Trump said
get me McShea and they thought they said
McDonald's and then that's what happened
that's true Todd mentioned is that is
that exactly what happened last night
with Compson in the house last night I
think so what a mess what do you think
do you know do you know Clemson's
nutritionist Todd have you met the
person who apparently is is one job is
to make sure the kids don't eat fast
food you heard about that I actually
haven't I've got our balance I've been
to the facility I've not met that person
but I can not imagine that he mmm all
those burgers out there I'm sure he dove
into one himself
all right let's dive into the the main
story on the menu today and that's
that's calamari Todd let's start with
the evaluation of Murray as it currently
stands with him saying he's now eligible
to be drafted in 2019 in the NFL Todd
there's a lot of layers I mean the first
thing and the most obvious thing that
everyone's gonna point is and at the
combine we'll all be sitting there he is
he five eight and a half five nine what
is he but and then I think just as
importantly his weight and thickness I
can he hold up he look at Russell Wilson
he's 510 3/8 inches but he's also 205
and I do think one thing to Tyler does a
really good job of like Russell does is
is protect himself a lot of it was
because he had four point seven billion
this year maybe some more well but at
some point you got to get concerned if
he's only 180 pounds now I'm I'm a
little bit more concerned about the
baseball aspect of it because I have a
really good friend when my best friends
from growing up as it works a major
league baseball and in the offices in
New York and he's been texting me all
week long about the art if he goes he
goes 15 what's the money he goes 30
three what's the money clearly and I
didn't ask him but clearly he's getting
questions from me A's and B's baseball
wants him to be a major league baseball
player because he could be one of the
faces of that sport so what happens if
if he's just leveraging football over
baseball warranty really legitimately is
going to play football for one or two
years but it fails and then you you lose
out he goes back to baseball so those
are the two things now on the positive
side needs electrified obviously these
to me is explosive a quarterback in
athletic a quarterback as we've seen
since Michael Vick he also is very
accurate
he has touch he goes to his progression
reads quickly he does so many of the
little things well that you wouldn't
think a quarterback with only fourteen
College starts does so I think he can be
a legitimately good starter in the NFL a
difference maker a playmaker and I would
draft him in the first round if I was
guaranteed that he would make football
the number one priority and give me at
least four years to try to work it out
Todd makes a here on the Rich Eisen show
it on I said at the opening of the show
I said upon hearing he might actually
declare and then after he declared and
I'll repeat it again here you know
exactly what you just said you know
Talent evaluators in the NFL and you
know how much they can fall in love with
talent all it takes is one as the famous
phrase obviously to just draft anybody
that has some question marks about
physical attributes or anything like
that but it's the the desire to play
football that everybody's got to be
lockstep on and that everybody who
evaluates talent has room for three FS
Faith Family and football there's no
room for A's Todd there's no room for
Red Sox there's no room for Yankees
there's no room for any of that don't
you think he has to declare one way or
another at some point and if so when is
that point do you believe
I think he does if he wants to be if he
wants to maximize what he can make I
mean to answer your question I think it
has to be before the combine I really do
because if they're gonna go through all
that because then he's got to either
show up to his training camp or he's got
a he's gotta be at home in 2 4 so I I
just I look at it this way you you can
probably go play football for two or
three years and then go back to baseball
I don't think you can go play baseball
and then come back to football at the
quarterback position and I definitely
don't think you can do both it's not
like Bo Jackson
it's not like Deion any of the other
dual sport players if you're playing a
position you know wide receiver corner
they're running back that's fine but not
quarterback you cannot do both in my
opinion so he's got he has to declare
and he's gonna have to convince teens in
a very short period of time that he's
joining us really to completely commit
to football for multiple years and to
give it a full shot I don't know no ice
at no weight to the I agree and we all
wish it was Brian Griese and I said
Steve Levy we're sitting in the room
everyone assumed and I think it was late
October before the Texas Tech goal that
he was he was a one and done every
stalker that has that area said you know
we're not even really evaluating because
he's either going to come back to school
or he's gonna go play major league
baseball next year and so I asked him I
said where are you in the process is
there any indication if he's going to
come back to school has any chance of
playing in the NFL because I think
Lincoln that he could he could play at a
high level and he said I agree said I
think he's a first-round pick we
promised each other we wouldn't talk
about until the end of the year and that
was the first time I had gotten any
indication that he was thinking about it
but now now that he's come out and said
that he's declaring for the NFL Draft
also no Scouts in addition to on in full
commitment they're a sceptical Bunch and
understandably and they're gonna dig and
dig and dig to try to figure out is he
legitimately trying to do this or
is this a leverage button is he trying
to make more money because he could off
of his initial contract guaranteed money
made 10 to 15 million dollars more than
that 4.7 million this year it has
guaranteed by the ACE being a
first-round pick
Todd McShea here on the Rich Eisen show
before the combine I'm listening I'm
thinking maybe the A's lies ice you know
are enlightened enough to basically say
you know go see if there are other fish
in the sea go so your NFL Wild Oats and
then come home and let him go to the
combine and let him go there and
obviously being somebody who's sitting
in that booth for four straight days on
live television on the NFL Network I
sure hope that happens I hope that being
creative already shows up there and and
if he can handle all the questions cuz
that's when it would come you know all
it forget about spinning it on on the
field and going through the drills I'm
sure he'll be dynamite at that and he'll
blow away the 40-yard dash line too it's
it's the meeting it's the medical it's
the measurements and all that but it's
the meetings at night when the coaches
and evaluators gonna look them in the
eye and say well what gives with the ACE
do you want to do this or not
and he can sit there and go up down left
and right and talk about how much he
loves it but at some point he's got to
declare and if you think it's before the
combine then he's got to do that pretty
damn darn fast Todd yeah yeah no you're
right and if you gets to the combine
that's gonna be the interesting part
because as you well know the
psychologists that are in the room it's
not just the scouts and offensive
coordinator head coach general manager
in some situations I'm sure even an
owner in this situation but they most
teams have a psychologist sitting in the
room and I think it would be fascinating
and I don't know that we'll get the
answer for years but it would be
fascinating to listen to or
psychologists talk about how he answered
the questions and you know how he
presented himself and if they
legitimately bought the story I mean you
can't think we can't put a polygraph on
them
but other than that you're trying to do
everything you can to try to figure out
if he legitimately wants to do this
because there is there is a place for
leverage and
we've already heard there's reports out
there about the ACE talking to Major
League Baseball trying to get exemptions
to try to figure out ways to pay him
more to make sure that he comes and
plays for them in Major League Baseball
and so to me this is one of the most
fascinating pre-draft stories that I've
been a part of in 20 years of covering
the draft I agree with you I agree with
you Todd it wouldn't it be great if one
of the teams like hires Robert DeNiro
and they have like a meet the parents
scene strolls into the meeting room
somewhere sit down talk about a circle
of trust right you know Tom McShea here
on the Richardson show who's uh who's
number one right now your best guess is
at Bosa could it possibly be Haskins how
do you see this playing out shuffling
now that we know who's in the mix Todd I
think and Quinton Williams the defensive
tackle from Alabama are the two best
football players in this draft I also
picked the first five teams you could
look at the quarterback situation and
there's not a desperate need necessarily
who knows you know good friend Jon
Gruden has a little bit of quarterback a
DD so you never know where that's going
to go but I think if you look at the
history and most importantly the recent
history Cleveland couldn't trade trade
up because they had the first pick but
just about every other team the last few
years has traded up to go get
quarterback so it won't shock me if it's
the Giants moving up from six
Jacksonville from seven maybe even
Denver from ten if there's some movement
to go up to to get a quarterback Haskins
could wind up going a lot earlier than
maybe people expected but I legitimately
do think he's a top shelf
first-round quarterback that deserves to
be drafted in the top ten the more I
study of him the more I really
appreciate his game I'd love to see more
than 14 starts but you know true Biscay
had 13 starts we scrutinized that he
hasn't been great but he's been good
enough and and I think we'll go through
the whole process with with Haskins and
I I really do think when we get to the
draft there will be a lot of people
they're comfortable with Haskins as a
top ten pick and who knows where Tyler
teams were convinced it wouldn't shock
me if he was in the top 10 15 picks
overall well hitting isn't amazing I
mean this wouldn't even been considered
five years ago prior prior to the rpoS
and the college offense being more it
really has in it the more coaches I talk
to and the more you study the tape the
more you have to just kind of let go of
the old you really do it doesn't have to
be six five in the pocket stat to get
the ball out all those things it can be
under sized moving around creating your
own passing lanes
I mean Drew Brees a 6-foot Russell
Wilson's 510 and three-eighths inches
Baker Mayfield I mean all of these guys
that are having success and I understand
that they're still you know Phillip
Rivers and and Tom Brady and so on and
so forth but the game is changing to
more of a spread tempo game where
undersized quarterbacks can succeed in
the league and I think you're ignorant
if you don't start realizing that and it
probably took me a year or two too long
to start realizing it and Tom McShea
then there's two will coming down the
pike and then Trevor Lawrence I mean
holy crap him being 6-4 6-2 we're six
five or whatever he might be and we
asked this question on our on our poll
question after the national championship
game we asked to my colleague and your
counterpart and Daniel Jeremiah I'd love
to ask you the question we we said if
you could take stock over the next ten
years in somebody and we gave you Trevor
Lawrence we gave you to a or anybody
drafted in the 2018 draft class that's a
quarterback who would you choose what
would you take and to be totally honest
with you it would have been I don't want
to say 50/50 I would have leaned Trevor
before the game but head to head
watching that it was there was a clear
difference why and to step up in that
stage and to be nervous early that was
the other thing that really impressed me
his first three throws scared me because
he you know he was
forcing it he was uncomfortable but to
settle down on that stage against
admittedly not the best Alabama defense
but a defense that throws so many
different looks at you and it has so
much talent even though it's not the
best it was really impressive to me and
I just I think that that was one of the
one of the moments that you watch is
almost like watching the Andrew Luck you
know when you just you're so certain
that if things work out health-wise he's
just going to be a great bro and time
will tell but I also knowing about him
and sitting now addabbo and sitting down
with their offensive coaches about how
much sure he is for his age and how he's
kind of he's been developed the right
way he's just he's a special dude and
he's different and I think it'll be a
major surprise if he's not a very good
starter in the NFL when he gets his shot
DJ said he's still sticking with Sam
Donald Todd you wouldn't come off of
that
yeah head to head Sam Trevor right now
all right I'll take I'll take Trevor but
I wouldn't I mean I'm a huge Sam guy so
maybe that's what case was thinking
about looking around the he's thinking
about the same thing maybe that's what
he's thinking about looking around the
press conference room that's that's what
that's what everybody is thinking right
now we're hearing some teams are already
thinking about to a year out right now
Todd that's no joke all right you want
to ask to ask Todd the poll question
before you let him go
all right Todd what's the best football
movie varsity blues remember the Titans
any given Sunday Rudy Friday Night
Lights or Brian song oh I love the show
Friday Night Lights yep I think Remember
the Titans is the one that would make me
tear up and like get really emotional so
that would probably probably be my
favorite Varsity Blues Doh rich I'm cut
I'm disappointed in you
is that that's I've never seen
Vanderbeek Roos I know you don't want my
life right yes Todd I'm I'm always
honest with you and my listeners and
viewers every single day I shoot you
straight I've never seen varsity blues
so what's your what's your one sports
movie that you're you're ashamed to
admit that you haven't seen know that I
haven't seen yeah
yeah I don't know I think you see I
don't have you seen them all I haven't
seen them all but I can't think of one
that's like it's significant that I
haven't she's Mackay's or he's he's more
up on it well yeah look Todd you watch
varsity blues how old are your kids not
yet we're not ready yeah the five year
old probably shouldn't see the scene
where they go all night good parenting
Todd thanks for that evaluation I
appreciate that
take care thanks for the call all right
yeah that's Todd McShea at McShea 13 the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience